it's 6 43 also new this morning getting
veterans the care they need Disabled
American Veterans is a non-profit it's a
group which gets those who have served
two life-saving appointments
unfortunately because of a lack of
volunteers they've really had to cut
down on how many veterans they can
assist Candice Charles joining us live
from the VA Hospital North Las Vegas
with more on the impact and then really
how you at home can help turn things
around Candace good morning
they certainly can have their good
morning Heather and John good morning
folks yeah DAV says prior to the
pandemic they were doing about 500
appointments a month now less volunteer
drivers that number has gone down
drastically Nationwide the DAV helps a
million veterans with claims in making
sure they get to and from their
appointments at no charge drivers take
veterans to dialysis sometimes two to
three times a week chemo or any
appointment they may have and it makes
the world of difference guys this is
Mike and Robert here Mike drives Army
vet Robert to his early morning dialysis
appointments
the whole program shrunk down a whole
lot from what it used to be and we're
trying to build it back up but until we
get more drivers we can't really get
more Riders Wednesday for example we had
three drivers working we had nine
patients but we had a couple one call in
he has colon cancer but we couldn't give
him a ride because we just didn't have
enough people to do that
and that certainly is a shame now before
the pandemic delveined there from DAV
said they had about 50 drivers here in
Nevada now they are down to 10 and Mike
says excuse me
his list includes about 250 veterans 40
of them are regulars now if you'd like
to be a volunteer driver you can call
that number on your screen or you can go
to our website newsnow.com for more
details for now live from the VA
Hospital out in North Las Vegas I'm
Candace Charles 8 News Now
it's important to get the the men and
women who have served to these
appointments and a ride can just be so
beneficial so yeah thanks again